thanks everybody for actually uh being
physically here it's always nice to see
bodies
and uh
um uh yeah so I'm uh uh to give you a
tiny snippet of uh so I'm Chris Hammond
I'm with narrative science
um I'm also on uh the uh in the
engineering school at Northwestern and a
tiny little piece of my soul is owned by
Madill which is the journalism school at
Northwestern but right now I'm on leave
and focusing on uh what's going on at
narrative science
um
we are we work on transforming data into
stories
um and uh we're going to see I'm going
to show you a lot of stories
um and uh the uh stories is an odd word
for it and that sometimes it's a story
sometimes you call it a broader
narrative sometimes you call it a report
sometimes you call it a tweet
but we take raw numerical data and
symbolic data and we turn them into
stories
um and so I'm actually just going to go
to the punch line right away
um so this is a numerical representation
of a basketball game
um and uh it's a relatively recent one
but it is a uh uh a Nebraska Wisconsin
game
um uh for those of you who are huge
sports fans who is a huge sports fan
here
and I didn't think there'd be a massive
number just so you know just you know I
too I too am an engineer
um uh uh
um but we take that
uh and we turn it into this and I mean
literally that and turn it into this
Ryan Evans scored 22 points and grabbed
six rebounds uh to lift number 11
Wisconsin to a 64-40 win over Nebraska
on Tuesday at Bob Denver Lee Sports
Center of Lincoln Evans and Jordan uh
Taylor both had solid performances for
Wisconsin who's doing uh who's uh 12-2
Evans made uh nine of 11 shots from the
floor Taylor had 15 points and
contributed seven assists scoring uh
that few points in rare for Nebraska a
team that came in averaging 66.8 points
per game this season the Badgers held
the Corn Huskers the 31 shooting from
the field hauled in 25 defensive boards
while only allowing eight offensive
rebounds and just nine three uh and just
nine uh free throw attempts Wisconsin
hit 51 percent of its field goals the
Badgers were hot from long range lifting
11 of 21 uh threes for a 52 night from
Beyond The Arc
um my favorite line on this is winning
the battle on the boards was crucial for
Wisconsin as a grabbed 30 rebounds to 24
for the Corn Huskers with the win the
Badgers extend their winning streak to
six games
um we uh we're doing this for uh the Big
Ten Network
um uh we do basketball uh we do football
uh this is a a mid game uh uh a mid game
uh story for football we do quarterlies
and finals
um uh our favorite thing is that for
um uh for football we'll do the uh uh
we'll do the quarterly the game the
quarter will end we'll we'll get the
data we'll write the story we'll deliver
the story and the story we'll be back on
will be online before the Big Ten gets
back from this commercial break
which excites us tremendously excites
them tremendously and I wanted to excite
you tremendously
how accurate yeah oh my God it's
directly from the numbers we've never
made a mistake
no no no it's it's all based upon the
numbers that I mean we treat the numbers
as ground in some sense it's ground
truth although we don't quite treat her
as Grand truth
yes we do and we can talk about that
later when we talk about Finance
um
uh uh but I giving you the punch line
and now we're gonna back up a little bit
um because I want to give you some
context as to where all this is coming
from
um and uh step you through a couple
things and then we'll get back uh we'll
get back to this uh so I'm out of the uh
I'm out of the uh Yale AI group of the
80s
oh absolutely we're not going to talk
about Roger all morning
um uh went to uh University of Chicago
um I started working on uh Plan
Generation uh uh moved over to
Northwestern University uh and uh
started something called the info lab uh
and then started working with the
schools of both engineering and
journalism and content generation and
now have shifted over to actually
commercializing this uh effort uh at
narrative science
um just and I'm I'm really not going to
talk about this but I I got I'm gonna
race you through this just to give you a
real context for what this is all about
so my starting point in terms of what I
was doing uh was artificial intelligence
um in particular a brand of artificial
intelligence called case-based reasoning
and it was simply the idea that when you
see a new problem
you remember an old problem you remember
an old solution and you reuse the
solution that is that you do not when
you get up in the morning and figure out
how to get dressed make breakfast and
get to work you do not do that reasoning
from first principles you just do it
because you've been doing it all all
along and it always works
um
um uh uh if it works it rather that you
have a choice you have a choice in terms
of uh and I don't want to talk about
planning
um you have a choice in terms of uh in
terms of running plans either
you can just run a plane that works and
it might be sub-optimal or you can sit
in a room by yourself for the rest of
your life and think it through now that
would be that and that would be that
would be the choice uh so we looked at
we we really were starting from the
point of view that reasoning is
remembering
right Something Old Something New new
thing comes in remember the old you use
it
now it's super important to understand
that I was a very serious scientist at
the time
um uh and in particular
uh I was a True Believer in terms of AI
uh and I continue to be a True Believer
in terms of AI uh I believe that um that
uh it is only a matter of time before
every single aspect of cognition
um will be modeled in the machine
that there is it's un there's no
question about it there's no arguing uh
and uh it's simply going to happen
but
while we were working on what we were
working on we had this moment where we
something occurred to us is that we
really loved the idea of reasoning is
remembering but then we thought maybe we
could remember other people's stuff
that is rather than thinking about it as
we're creating a system we're creating a
system that is
um uh trying to run plans based upon a
corpus of plans instead we would start
thinking about systems that would do
something else
um uh and we had a bit of a refocus and
that refocus was uh into uh frictionless
information systems and frictionless
information systems were based upon the
idea that
um rather than using a text box as the
way to get to information you want to
use the context of what you're doing and
in particular our starting point for
this was if I'm writing or reading
something I want to do an analysis of it
and then I want to use that analysis to
drive search so I find pertinent
information that is important for me in
the moment that I'm doing work and I
want that search to proceed without
having any effort on my part
right and I want it to be on point
um so the notion here was that our
starting point was text that is the text
that we were reading the text that we
were writing our techniques were both
statistical and heuristic right I get I
I do a histogram of the the unigrams the
bigrams the trigrams I figure out what's
important there I notice that some
things are in bold and some things are
more towards the top of a document that
means they're more important
um so a bit of statistics and a bit of
heuristics but our substrate was search
that is rather than thinking about
memory in terms of well-structured data
well-structured representations we were
thinking about we were thinking about
our our process in terms of uh using a
noisy substrate search itself our
technology was based upon query
formation that as I see something new
um I'd figure out what's going on with
it I use it to drive the formation of
queries and our product with search
results
and our core point was that context can
drive search and in fact context is a
tremendous driver of search and our job
was the support of content production it
was the support of other things but a
good way to think about it is I'm
creating something I'm writing something
and I want to get information coming to
me that's going to participate in what
I'm writing
now it turns out that we can use almost
anything as a starting point so that the
very Act of touching a book will get you
information from the online World about
that book that is really what is the
book what's going on with it or the
similar books the reviews quotes author
information
um which is essentially saying you touch
a book you get a website
it's the same notion I've got something
here in my hand and it's a driver for
finding other things for me
of course there are other things the
world besides pieces of text
and we'd realize that we could start
with anything
and that is anything that had a barcode
and once we scanned it
we could get information about it and we
might actually be providing uh we might
be able to get something that is
sometimes more powerful than information
that is the ability to take action on it
and so you would find not only all the
things that you would want in terms of
reviews and trailers and recommendations
but the ability to say Oh no just this
is good for me now put it to my next
Netflix queue and the idea of course was
to start treating uh the world as a
catalog
and of course there's any metadata
um and so if you've got a video
and that video has metadata around it
describing it if it has closed
captioning associated with it you can
use it as a driver for search and in
this case it's a an episode of Good Eats
so we get stuff about Alton Brown
because we know he's the host
we get related videos that is other
videos that are from either the show or
people talk about the show people
blogging about Alton Brown in the show
from the web because we know the show
this particular episode was about corn
dogs we find information about corn dogs
including my favorite the history of the
corn dog
uh crucial to anybody
um uh we know what the plan is what we
know what the plan is associated with
this
um uh and so we can get the tools
associated with that plan and then we
can get a collection of recipes
now there's a thread that follows
through all of these
and to really
uh simple idea is that we were Building
Systems that exerted editorial control
over their processes that is if you look
at what you want to do if you're
building something that's going to take
arbitrary videos and then go find
information associated with them you
actually have to know that this is a
how-to video this is a sitcom this is a
drama this is news you have to treat the
information you gather from them in
different ways and you have to go find
different things associated with them
and so what editorial control Meant For
Us was
what to look for
where to look for it what to filter out
how to label it and how to show it
um and this was super exciting for us in
terms of a transition and understanding
what we were doing
but of course there's that moment where
you ask yourself if you're going to do
that why not go the last mile
why not actually write the story
I want to actually turn it into
something that's not a list of results
but is a synthetic document or a
synthetic experience that actually uh
that actually pulls all this information
into one place one place that can be
ingested as a whole
um so what do you need to do that
well you really need to if you're going
to write a story you need to know what
the story is going to be about
um and then if you're if you're a
substrate a search you want to know what
uh elements of that story you're gonna
go look for
um you know I didn't need to know where
to look for those elements you know you
need to know which of the set of things
that you found you're going to use
you got to figure out how to label them
to a great extent in terms of topic and
sentiment
um and how to compose those elements
into a single thing
we should just say what you need
is you need to structure
what's usually referred to as the
narrative Arc
that is that you you need that and if
you don't have that then how can you
pull it all together how can you make it
into a coherent whole how can you have
it make sense
and so we started thinking about what
would it mean to build a system that
actually kind of knew what it was doing
in terms of constructing something and
then we'd go find things that would
become the elements of that system
um so we built a thing called news at
seven
um and we'll see uh we'll see how our
microphone does here
and where this thing is going to show up
that actually worked pretty well
director Ricky Gervais stars with Golden
Globe Jennifer Garner and Golden Globe
nominee run blue in the film Invention
of Lying this movie is a comedy set in a
world where no one has ever late until
later seizes the opportunity for
personal gain it is a PG-13 rated comedy
I loved this movie
in the same animal quiet PG-13 way The
Invention of Lying as a remarkably
radical comedy
comedies that hasn't taken those ideas
through enough drafts to work out their
implications were harder still make them
Killingly funny
you get the idea of what it is
uh the input to the system is the name
of movie
um uh the system knows about
movie reviews it knows how the removal
reviews should be structured
um it knows about a whole bunch of
different sources it can go to so it
goes to IMDb and it finds out everybody
who was associated with that movie
um it goes to Metacritic and rotten
tomatoes and it finds out how what
people thought of the movie and
depending upon what they thought of that
movie
um it said it picks the particular
Dynamic that it's going to put together
and then it puts that Dynamic together
and so the notion here is that we have a
structure
um and we've got things like well we
want to intro the film we want to save
we want to say in general people like it
or disliked it we want to say something
about the story so if we want to see
something positive about the story we're
going to go look for a sentence that's
positive about the invention of line
with words like story plot writing
message if we want to say something
negative about the acting well again
we're going to look for a sentence for
this that with the the affect is is
negative the sentiment is negative
invention of line with Ricky Gervais
performance acting
because we're going to look for these
all these components and because we know
the structure to begin with we can fit
these components together put in some
interstitial material
shove it through a a text-to-speech
system an animation system go and find
the b-roll and Bam we actually have the
right dynamic
um uh the uh the throttle in this of
course is the uh is text-to-speech
because uh much as I love the uh the
world and everything that's been done in
it it still is the fact that
text-to-speech sounds like it's uh been
done by a computer
um
it doesn't sound quite that bad but it's
but it's pretty bad
um uh even there was a wonderful uh
experiment that was done where uh when
Roger Ebert lost his voice uh due to uh
due to cancer
um uh somebody took uncommon together
all of a lot of his
um shows and put together a synthesized
version of him and he said you know it
sounds like me it also sounds like a
machine
um uh and getting affected is almost
impossible
um uh right now
um but the idea here is that because we
have the structure and the structure
tells us what to look for we can go look
for it we can find it
now
there's this funny thing
and that is everything here was built on
this substrate of
uh
search
a substrate of text
uh and
um it still is the case that for any
individual piece of text
actually deriving the unambiguous
meaning of that piece of text is
difficult
um uh so we thought well
why not we go why don't we try a world
in which there is no ambiguity in which
there's clarity
in which the things that we're looking
at have distinct meanings which are
absolutely and utterly unambiguous
so we looked at data and we thought why
not build narratives off a substrate of
data and data analytic analytics rather
than search itself
and that is let the Data Drive what
we're doing
so we started with sports uh and there's
the example this is my punchline example
um our first foray into this was
actually
um uh was actually a men's college
baseball
um uh we actually when we began we had a
choice we had to do
um Sports
or we could do finance
and Prime and for the same basic reason
that is for both of them there was a
tremendous amount of data online
we could get to it easily we kind of
knew what the stories would be and we
could use that as a driver we were very
lucky in that we had a journalism
student who was working with us
who uh was a Stringer for the Chicago
Tribune doing High School uh football
stories
um and uh he said let's do Sports and so
we gave it to him and uh a another
journalism student who's also a
developer
um and they built the first version of
this thing
um
uh we very quickly went on to look at
football
and then basketball
uh we now do hockey as well we do a lot
of work for the Big Ten because they
they fell in love with us
um uh and uh the notion here is that we
can do a game story
a preview
an in-game recap
um uh so quickly and so accurately that
they really don't need to put their
resources behind that they put their
resources elsewhere
um we also had a moment where and it's
important for what we do as a company
and what we mean as an organization
where during the season because we were
doing women's softball as well because
once we did men's baseball we thought
let's do women's softball it's not a lot
different
um
we did women's softball as well and
during the season we are the premier
author uh the most prolific author of
women's softball college softball
stories in the United States and it's
primarily because we're almost the only
author
and uh we'll talk a little bit about
that we do little league now too we've
written on the order of of 350 000
Little League game stories
um and every once in a while when
somebody decides to get cranky with us
about uh we're taking jobs away from
journalists
um uh I point out that I have never seen
a damn journalist at a little league
game
um and if they would like to cover
Little League they can cover little
league but in the meantime we'll cover a
little league
um
we quickly moved on to finance
same sort of notion
tremendous amount of data
most of the data that we use in the
finance work we do now comes from our
clients
but you get data like the the uh the
stock history for a company what all the
analysts feel about this company uh who
their competitors are
estimates from the analysts as to what's
going to be happening uh in a uh in
their next earnings statement and that
allows us to write this
earnings previews
um so since September 15 2011 Red Hats
stock is written 13.9 to close at 46.98
on December 13 2011. Red Hat will uh
we'll look to keep this momentum going
when it reports third quarter earnings
on Monday December 19th 2011.
um the notion here is again
uh we can we have can have reach
um that uh a straightforward a
traditional Media Company can't have and
so uh four of us might be able to do a
certain number of earnings previews
around the larger companies but we can
do instead of
or a hundred
or three hundred we can do 9 000.
because the data is there
the analysis is there the ability to
generate the text and to have the text
be different every single time we
generate it is all there
our next step
real estate
and here we have a client who gives us
data on home sales in about 350 Metro
areas
and they it was a actually a lovely
moment and to the uh to the uh fellow
who was asking about you it was you you
about visualization
it was you I'm sorry you were in you're
very close though uh
um uh this company and they have
beautiful data they have beautiful data
it's wonderful it's complete and they
put together for their customers
absolutely Stellar gorgeous graphs
and we had a meeting with them and I was
actually kind of crushed because I
looked at the graphs and I said oh
I said you don't need us
clearly your customers are amazingly
data Savvy and they were able to look at
these things and just draw a tremendous
amount of insight from them and the guy
was like you you are just so wrong
um
and so what we do for them is every
month
we write a uh we write a recap an
overview of what's going on these Metro
areas from the point of view of in
particular new home sales
um and there are numbers in a lot of
what we do because a lot of our clients
want numbers but my favorite thing is
newest home sale number newest newest
newest new home sale numbers give hints
uh give hints market decline is
deepening yes
no no no we're getting to it I'm giving
you some examples of where we're like
two slides one slide away damn it
ah
that moment where you're hungry for it
but I got to give you I got to give you
a little breath here
um how does it work uh it's uh it's
actually kind of uh fun so our starting
point is always the data
right raw data either numeric or
symbolic
has to be unambiguous
all right and that's that's actually
kind of huge it has to be unambiguous uh
what we do with that data is we do
various uh statistics we run various
statistical analyzes in the data and
sometimes not even statistical analyzes
but just simple math on the data and
comparisons so for example if you have a
game if you have data on a game
and I and I've got Northwestern another
Northwestern 10 Michigan 8
. in the data itself it never actually
says Northwestern won the game
it's just not there and so you have to
do a simple little thing and say which
of these numbers is bigger
right
um more interesting is streaks more
interesting is Seasons more interesting
is uh players ups and downs more
interesting is slumps more interesting
is is it a blowout but that's the next
step so we go from data to some a little
bit statistical analysis to facts right
and these are these are expressed still
at the data level but our newly derived
features and we tend to call them
derivations uh newly derived features
that we can uh we can do something on
and that something is testing
um so there's the notion and uh there's
a notion in sports of uh a blowout
right a blowout is one team just hammers
the other
um there's a back and forth the lead
goes back and forth between the uh the
two teams there's an early Victory very
early on in the game somebody makes
somebody somebody scores well and they
hold on to that lead
uh there's a come from behind
all of these are characterizations of
the patterns that you see as a game
progresses
along with that though there were things
like
heroic effort
and a heroic effort is when it's one guy
who actually made the difference
there's team effort there's pitchers
duel in baseball
there's lots of yards no scoring
right so you've driven you keep driving
that ball down and you never get it over
the goal line
um all of these are things that we call
angles
yes
make stories interesting and unique from
each other
um uh for I would say for
um uh for most of our Sports uh we have
a few hundred
um but what's great
uh is that come from behind
come from behind Scopes over a lot of
things
uh uh it's really it's really kind of
sweet uh and so once we do a vertical
um in a in a broad sense like sports
um uh we hold on to a lot of our angles
and reuse them
um
or detect no angles like if none of it
really fits good enough have enough
power to that's an excellent question
so next step uh uh
um uh yes and no
um uh here's the thing 18 months ago
this didn't exist at all in terms of
defining angles and running them
before we start uh doing intensive data
mining machine learning
um uh and uh
manipulating the data to find new things
automatically we want to do so uh using
humans and in fact what one of the
things I'm going to touch on in a moment
is that what we actually have is I think
a unique partnership between engineering
and editorial in terms of how we
actually proceed in doing these things
um all right so we have these angles and
these angles actually the term angle
here comes out of
um comes out of um journalism it's
what's the angle in the story it's a win
yeah but what's the angle on the story
was it a tremendous win was it a was it
a victory after a slump was it
um uh was it uh was it putting them over
the top in terms of their standings all
of those things yes
old AI World these were referred to as
ontological commitments yeah the issue
with the the one of the things we
learned about ontological commitments is
that sometimes
they could not they may not be as
consistent as we would like them to be
we don't write stories in general
we write stories
for particular clients
and so the ontological commitment that
we make in terms of what consists of
what what a blowout is
is the ontological commitment that the
writing staff at the Big Ten Network mix
I absolutely agree
okay I want to capture the definition of
this thing did you get the same
definition from every one of them no no
and there are there are minor
differences
but that means that the system is not
the system has a point of view
um and I would say there is no such
thing as ground truth in terms of what
constitutes a blowout
I mean there's just not
um it's all subjective the system has
its own subjective point of view and
here's a certain there's there's a
certainly important thing ontological
commitment
um uh
um it's a it's a lovely it's a lovely
term we never use it in the office
um uh because if we did the all my all
my editorial staff would simply walk
away
um uh we also don't use the term
taxonomy in the office
because they just it's like why are we
even listening to you and so when they
write stories they write stories from
their point of view and then they
negotiate with editor with the editorial
on the client side as to as to how that
story should be reshaped
um the uh even in terms of what is
important uh ends up being interesting
here
um and the Big Ten is actually a good
example here we uh at the beginning of I
don't know how you if you know how
conferences work uh but at the beginning
of the season
um all the all the teams in the Big Ten
will play outside of conf difference and
so Michigan will play
a Florida State
now every once in a while Florida state
will beat Michigan and we were writing
stories in an AP style and AP style
focuses on the winner
and we got a call from our our editorial
guy at the Big Ten and he said you know
my audience is the Big 10 people
they really care about the Big Ten team
and they really don't want to hear about
and he wasn't angry he was just like
explaining it to us he said they really
don't want to hear what a great team
Florida state has fielded
um could you could you mention something
about the Big Ten
um and uh so what we did is we tweaked
these angles because one of the things
that these angles has or these angles
have is the notion of importance and
interestingness
importance is not quite objective but a
semi-objective notion of how important
an angle is interestingness is what does
it mean to the audience
um and each of the angles knows about
the its interestingness its importance
and the interestingness and importance
of other angles and so by changing uh
the interestingness of those angles the
one associated with the Big Ten
percolate to the top and even though
um uh even though it was a heroic
victory at the end of the game the fact
that it's a back and forth is what's
going to be mentioned in the headline
um is that the hook I mean some of the
angles the hook of the story yes
um and and hook would be another term
for it absolutely
so we got all
and remember I talked about the ark
that's this
that's the notion that
um we don't have a story yet
we got data we got facts we got all the
angles but we don't have a story yet and
the structure says here's how I want you
to write this
get me a headline get me the lead get me
a paragraph about the most important
thing happening uh for the winning team
get me a paragraph that's really about
all what's going on in the pitching get
me a paragraph about some interesting
thing that didn't fall under this other
these other categories
um and that is used to drive
um uh to drive taking those angles and
integrating them into a larger structure
it is then and only then
that we hit language
and that is we have a representation of
what's happened and how we're going to
say it
and then we proceed to saying
um now there was a word I think you used
and that was template
um the system is not templated
um that is at the individual sentence
level it knows basically how to say
those sentences uh but there's a
tremendous amount of variability in what
it's doing
um both at the uh phrasal level and even
the sentence selection level and so for
any individual piece of content that it
wants to say it'll have maybe 20
different ways
structurally to say it and then within
those 20 ways it'll have a whole bunch
of selections of adjectives of even ways
of of describing players describing
companies that all participate in the
final language generation
all right
so when we hit
a new vertical because we now have a
very nice horizontal platform that's
configured
we asked the question what's the data
what can be derived from that data what
are the facts what are the angles what's
our take on this kind of story and what
are the angles in general how is this
kind of story going to be structured and
then what kind of language you're going
to use
now we actually do a lot of
um a lot of work in finance and we have
actually we have one client uh for uh
for preview stories for um earnings
previews so right before somebody makes
their earnings releases their earnings
to the uh to the SEC
um uh people are speculating about how
things are going and so there's an
earnings story around that company
um we have one client um who likes AP
Style and they're a justifax ma'am kind
of client
um and so we write in that style we have
another client that has a shockingly
irreverent Style
um and we write in that style as well
same facts same data same facts same
angles
slightly different story structure but
the language is all different
um you would never look the two stories
and have it occur to you at all that the
same person wrote it let alone that the
same device
wrote it
all right
so as I said this is a partnership
between engineering and editorial
um uh it always has been it always will
be when we talk to people about what
we're doing uh we'll always have
somebody in the engineering side who
will be talking about data how that data
is coming in how we're how we're loading
it how we're modeling it and we have
somebody on the on the editorial side
who's asking questions about well what
kind of story you want how do you want
to look how do you want to feel how do
you want to sound what's the tone what
do you want us to focus on
um and it's these two things together
um uh it's these two things together
that actually make I think make the the
technology make the company work
um of course uh
this is this this is another aspect of
uh talking about ontologies
um uh we our starting point when we
first built this it was a big wad of
python
it was about that big uh and then so we
had baseball it was a lot of python and
then we built football has a lot of
python
um uh and then we tore those apart and
we built a platform
which could be configured
the configuration though was done um and
this actually is still python uh the
configuration was done uh in yaml
um which I I gotta tell you I don't like
uh to begin with personally but I
someone who comes into uh comes into an
organization and they have unbelievably
Exquisite writing skills
and you explain to them that they're
going to be editing a configuration the
configuration for a system using a
representation language that
differentiates between four spaces and a
tab and so you have representational
differences between two files which are
invisible to the human eye
that that's really bad
and it's really mean uh so the tools we
gave them were a VI emacs
text Wrangler uh and at some point when
we're offline I'll tell you there was a
there was a text Wrangler moment I had
with it with one of our editorial that
was lovely
um that just doesn't work
um and so we decided to actually build a
tool set for them that actually
reflected what they were doing
um so from the from the first step they
have an outline they're able to say
here's the P here are the core pieces
that are going to go on in this story
and then within those core pieces
um those will expand out into components
that I can work on directly either the
sentence level the the the sentence
level the paragraph level level the
phrasal level
um and I can say things like you know I
got 10 angles that might participate in
this paragraph
um and they're kind of at odds with each
other because you ain't gonna have a
blowout and to squeak and to squeak
ahead you know those two things aren't
going to exist at the same time and so
we're going to be able to say I want a
paragraph about however you want to
characterize how this win went
um and depending upon that we're going
to say different things so the angles
are the drivers there in terms of making
uh the low-level decisions
the angles themselves are really just
tests on facts that we know about
and then the facts come out of
derivations coming from the core data
which are doing things like this is
actually for a political thing that I'm
going to show you at the very end
um
uh uh it's uh it's this is uh this is
overall traffic and given uh given the
traffic today well actually given the
traffic of day one uh which is actually
yesterday
um by the way that also annoys the hell
out of them that that that zero is the
starting point
um uh uh uh uh but because of the way
the system works I I wanted to start
with uh yesterday
um so uh uh day one sorted states which
is to say states with the most traffic
I'll give you the top one sorted
candidates give me the last one
um uh this is dead last this is the this
is a we're tracking the Republican
primaries does the candidate who uh uh
is mentioned at least
um
uh uh and then the models that is the
data itself that is finally touching it
down to the data level where we say for
each of these objects that we care about
here's how that object actually breaks
out into
um the initial data that we give it
um and then any derivations that are
going to be associated with it
do you ever derive new facts and if you
do do you use a Reasoner
um we use data analytics
which I am going to make the argument is
a Reasoner
simply would say if a then B if B then C
then I will drive if a then C
um if A and B and B then C oh yeah I
mean you mean did we change it doesn't
yeah that change oh absolutely that's a
reason right absolutely should you have
a Reasoner in the engine that it does
that
um we have an on-demand Reasoner that
uses
a numeric that does this that's based
upon uh numerical analysis plus some
symbolic analysis so yes we have
we have I mean it's a it's an AI system
absolutely I think that actually derives
the logic of the first order logic that
I just use as an example
how do I how do I put this
um
um yes
[Laughter]
would I actually ever express that to
any one who I'm talking to no I I know
reason or in absolutely and you've built
that Reasoner in python or yaml but in
Python sure it's only doing numerical
it's doing primarily numerical some
symbolic
um uh and it's not it's not a Reasoner
in it's a it's an on-demand reason where
it's only asking is this true and it
will do a little bit of reason to figure
out if it's true but all the angles are
uh the at the angles the angles all
actually bottom out in uh in in in
booleans and we we go from uh we go from
the numerical data to things that are
true in the world as a result of that
numerical data
but really there's an important Point
here for some things
are true in a story
um but I wouldn't ever argue that there
there's ground truth there but only
because I don't even I don't believe
there's ground truth anywhere and I
believe that whenever you form any sort
of approach towards having a one single
consistent ontology you're dooming
yourself to failure
um and and that 97 of the world is
subjective and interpretive
well within the confines of that we have
have we have a kick-ass reasoning system
um all right
so the result is the ability to do this
uh the ability to create
um to be able to create
um uh stories from uh data now
we were actually having a really good
time doing this
um we have about right now we we're uh
about 20 months old we have about 30
clients
um uh we have 34 people
um on staff which is amazing to me
um
but most of our clients in our early
days were media companies
so we would do Sports stories
we would do Finance stories
we would do
um uh stories in real estate
and although we always knew we were
going there
we realized that there was something
else that could be done
um uh and we could start looking at the
world of big data and we actually had a
pivotal moment with regard to this
where we were in a meeting with a woman
who is a VP of strategy for one of the
media companies we work for
um and literally a guy came in with one
of these and gave it to her
and she was like Jesus
and we were talking to her about Finance
stories
and she said well couldn't you guys do
something with this and she like starts
thumbing through it and spreadsheet
after spreadsheet after spreadsheet
well he asked her where she put them
and she said on this shelf and she said
I don't need a Shelf full of folders I
just need two paragraph summary of the
stuff that's important to me
um and that brought us into a different
world
where we came to understand that people
don't want this
they want this
they want this guy
this guy who could look at this
pull out the interesting important
Salient pieces of information and
explain it to somebody
and it's not just the data analytics
it's the ability to explain and in fact
in fact we uh we're we're actually in
the midst of looking we're doing a a
real intensive search for uh somebody uh
um in the realm of what we call the the
data scientist
um and if you look at all the
descriptions of the data scientists the
data scientist has to have really two
skills two primary skills one
unbelievable skills in terms of uh doing
data analytics the other is terrific
unbelievable communication skills so
they can understand why they're doing
this unbelievably terrific work in data
analytics
so they can figure out what it is they
want to say what it is what people want
to hear what should be communicated
um the it's all AI I I mean I I
um I gotta I gotta tell you if you I I
I'll share a couple examples a second so
but in story form
um uh we we this is the kind of thing we
were hearing from people we collect
everything on how each account is
performing but we only have the people
to explain it to our 10 biggest
customers
um you don't get the game from the stats
you get the game from the story they
tell and my favorite if I could spend a
half hour with each of our clients and
their data I could improve all of their
businesses
of course uh the client here is actually
uh franchisees and there were fourteen
thousand of them so that ain't going to
happen
um
but instead
we can do the following
um
we're actually in a pilot right now with
a client that
is a large fast foodie kind of
organization
and they they do they have 14 000 uh
franchises across the country they did a
really smart thing uh and that is
because everyone in the world knows that
in order to improve a business you have
to meter and monitor everything everyone
knows that and so they metered and
monitored everything so they gathered
point of sale information this is just
at the cut into slices for the uh the
time of day because if I showed you the
items you'd know what the customer or
the client was
um uh the uh they got point of sale
information for every single thing they
sell from 14 000 organizations and they
got they put in a box
and they said well this is going to be
great
because people are going to come
and look in this box
and this will help them
and it turns out that even when they
took that box and said here's the
spreadsheet for you
um they got about 10 penetration in
terms of people uptaking the data
um uh because if you run a fast food if
you're the if you're the owner of a fast
food organization you actually probably
started out not being the owner of a
fast food organization but some working
for a fast food organization and then
managing a fast food organization and
saving some money and buying a franchise
for a fast food organization
um and you're really not all that
interested in doing uh the data work
that you need to in order to get to
this
the launch of the bagels and cream
cheese promotion began this month while
your initial sales at the beginning of
the promotion were on track with both
your ad Co-op and the region your sales
this week dropped off from uh from last
week's 142 units down to 128 units your
morning guest count remains even across
Aquarium
taking better advances promotion should
help to increase guest count and overall
Revenue by bringing in new customers
the new item with the greatest growth
opportunity this week was the coffee
cake muffin
increasing your sales by just one unit
per thousand transactions to match sales
in the region that is we know that other
stores can sell this thing you're not
doing a good enough job would add
another 156 dollars to your monthly
profit that amounts to about uh uh
eighteen hundred and seventy two dollars
a year
it turns out that if you get that little
piece of paper
with that on it you actually read it and
you listen to it
um because this tells you what to do and
this is based on how you're doing the
fact that it's new how other people are
doing what the margin is on this item
and what what's the what's the one item
with the least number of sales you have
to change and the highest margin that
will have the greatest impact for you
now you can look at a spreadsheet and
figure that out you there's absolutely
no question about it
you won't do it you won't do it but you
will read this
absolutely
education
um
imagine you had 50 000 students
who were learning how to
who are ramping up on taking entrance
exams
uh and you had an online service for
them
and you had all their scores
now your online service is to a great
extent automated they can take the test
online the tests are scored
automatically
uh and now you want to talk to them
so what we do is we take those numbers
and we do the following
um you're in this 29th percentile in
phase four nationally and the 88th
percentile compared to your peers in any
kind USA your local area
uh your score has been fluctuating a
great deal over the course of the four
phases you need to work on your overall
consistency specifically you struggle
with the more difficult questions in all
three subject areas you're also missing
more of the moderate questions than your
peers which brings your scores down
think carefully before answering your
questions remember that you lose points
for every incorrect response you give
your scores are lower than they have to
be because your aunt because you answer
every question instead of skipping the
ones you don't
nice sweet piece of advice
um of course every single question
we know what it's a question about
and in fact we know what section of the
material it comes from
there are some ways in which you can
improve your scores in physics you
should focus your studies on the
sections dealing with magnetics and
electrostatics
these are topics on on which you score
the lowest your weakest area in
chemistry is aldehydes and ketones you
consistently Miss questions dealing with
that topic you also seem to have
difficulty with the easier questions
about nitrogen containing compounds
Matthew's our strongest subject but you
still miss a lot of the difficult
questions the topic of definite
integrals seems to uh seems to catch you
out most often
so we can give specific one-on-one
advice aimed at an individual based upon
those numbers yes
absolutely
it's there's there's the platform uh the
problem by the way the platform is
called narwhal uh which is the whale but
with two r's
um uh uh again we're a partnership
between engineering and editorial every
once while engineering names something
um
uh uh but this is all a single platform
a single platform going through the same
process data facts angles structure
language
all right
where am I oh I'm gonna I'm not I'm
gonna skip this one because even though
it's fascinating uh what
I got till 5 30. yeah one more minutes
oh oh I'm not gonna skip this one all
right
performance
um by the way the system also uh we we
haven't we haven't been paying attention
that we you know we we do what everybody
else does we meet her and monitor
everything because we got a lot of we
got a lot of machines that we ramp up
and ramp down we have to look at the
loads we have to look at memory we have
to look at this utilization we have to
look at all those things uh of course
that generates a lot of data
uh uh and uh uh we had a we had a
project for a while we're gonna bring it
back uh the system would actually talk
about itself uh and we talk about the
clients it was doing work for and the
difficulty was having on this machine
and maybe this machine was being over
utilized and maybe this machine was
being underutilized and we weren't
saving as much money and uh
Retreat uh um uh well actually we want
to have it we want to have a Blog just
just sitting here blogging about itself
oh man it was a busy day uh
uh
uh listen performance uh online uh
marketing services
so I want uh I want I want to put my ads
online
uh and so I go to an agency and I say
okay here here are the ads I want
um uh here are the creatives I'm going
to give you
um here are the demographics I care
about
um uh uh give them to me and here's the
here are metrics here's the here's the
target give them to me
you take all that stuff you put it into
a system and it's doing things like it's
buying some words
um it's uh it's making decisions about
what sites to put things on and you're
metering and monitoring this is by the
way the we can only talk to our top 10
customers
um
a ton of what you do is automated or
semi-automated but you're generating a
tremendous amount of data and the
question is as you scale something like
that if it's semi-automated you still
have people in the loop and that's fine
but you can scale it but if you scale it
in a way that means that you can no
longer talk to your clients you're kind
of messing yourself up as a company
because you can't have those
conversations and those clients go away
um
uh so what we did was we took a look at
their data
and we did uh client-based performance
reporting so this week's performance is
looking exceptionally good in the past
three weeks we have seen a nearly 20
rise in Click through with the figure
moving from uh 0.11 which is a good fine
number in the middle of the week of
March 24th uh to 0. uh one three percent
this week
um uh things pulling out things like the
biggest channel channel driver is still
the news and information channel that
has an overview overall click rate
click-through rate of uh 0.1 percent up
from a 0.12 a month ago
um this is actually just a
straightforward positive report
um there's an interesting thing that
happens and that's what happens if you
want to say something negative
so you have a client
and you've messed something up and I'm
not even talking about marketing
Services you have a client and you mess
something up
if you're going to tell them that you
messed something up what else do you
want to tell them
anybody
yeah how to fix it how to fix it awesome
um and so part of this and it's not in
this example I'm sorry part of this is
you're not hitting the demographic that
you wanted to hit
we suggest the following changes
um uh and so in the next iteration we
should do it the following way and the
notion here is that you can actually
have
I I hate to use the word but it's the
it's the real word you can you can
actually have a personal relationship
mediated by the machine with clients
um uh that explain the good
expose the bad uh and then bring them on
to the fixes
um and this is a really powerful tool by
the way we also
uh we also we also do graph Generation
Um but any anyone anyone can do that
golly graph Generation
Um
okay so we're kind of walking into
everything uh because it's amazing uh
there's just there's so much data
um and everybody's got it
um uh in Pharma we're looking at the
idea of uh taking the data generated uh
through clinical trials and and creating
clinical reports
um uh in politics polling information
Sports you can see it Finance you can
see it real estate you've seen it sales
you know down to the level of looking at
performance comparisons of your
different sales uh your different
salesmen looking at how they're doing in
the different markets which markets are
doing bad are doing better or worse
where you should put your emphasis
um all grounded in data
um
the reality is is that wherever there is
data
we can tell a story
one tiny Proviso
wherever there is
structured data and in fact I actually I
I I'm there are two there are two terms
that I I tend to use uh uh or I have
have buggables about I tend not to call
it computers computers I call them
machines it's like bring it to the
machine
um uh my CEO explained to me that just
scared the hell out of everybody
whenever I did that
um because they understood computers but
when I was like well and the Machine is
there isn't it uh it just they they find
it very disturbing I I I'm trying to
break myself of that habit
um uh the other is the word data
um uh everybody the the there's a the
term big data has been floating has been
has really been popping a lot recently
um uh and uh there's a great
um
uh uh there's a uh a great quote I think
I I think it was Balmer
um who commented that
um uh from the dawn of civilization to
uh to today or or to 19 to 2005.
um you know the the World created Five
terabytes of data uh and then we now do
that every two days
and it's but it's not data
um uh and uh for what we do it's always
important for us to think in terms of
there's data and which I mean machine
readable unambiguous structured
uh and there's information human
readable unstructured floating about in
the world
um
and we need this structured
but you might say
what about the instructured world
there's so much out there
um
uh and we do have an effort in uh we do
have an effort in natural language
processing where we're reading headlines
uh but that's too hard
I just think it's hard
um uh it's not hard in the aggregate
though
um uh what about this world uh the
Twitter world the social media world
well
we do
is we track it and we tag it
uh and we do the simplest things that
you can imagine that is we Define
categories of things that are associated
with
um particular verticals we look at the
words and phrases that are associated
with those verticals we provide tools
for quickly mining those words and
phrases and uh building out these uh
tagged uh these tagged Collections
and so we can take a look at for example
all the the traffic around the
Republican candidates and we can see
most there's most the people who are
tweeting about the Republican candidates
are also talking about Obama so there's
a lot of uh talk about endorsements uh
campaign and fundraising issue issues
concessions uh the Tea Party and so
forth
so we can structure it
and then we write stories because that's
what we do
it's our only skill uh
we've seen a bit of an uptake in uh
political talk today right now the
country is concerned about the
Republicans and Obama the topic takes
the lead but there's also considerable
talk about endorsements and campaign and
fundraising issues
there's also a lot of traffic about John
Huntsman dropping out of the race a few
days ago
if the traffic is any indication it
looks like Huntsman is out of the
running and here are a couple of tweets
that actually are indicative of that
traffic around Ron Paul remained High
over the last two days and it has in
fact dominated the conversation for the
past week the country is talking about
him with a focus on Obama there's also a
fair amount of traffic related to
people's take on Paul and endorsements
um and then we pull out the things that
are being shared the most often the
videos that are being shared a couple of
tweets
and we go through the usually the top
two and then the dead last
um uh but there are certain features
which if they pop up again importance
um percolite to the top they don't quite
make it to the lead because the lead is
really all about
um the lead is all about traffic but
they do pop up uh high enough to get to
uh what's called The Nut graph that
first uh graph where you're starting to
you're starting to give some color to a
story
what the headline is people are talking
about Obama as Ron Paul continues to
lead the online chatter not online
chatter so
yeah
um and
what currently Industries nobody
this is an alpha what are your plans
um we're gonna just put it online and
let people see it
this is totally this is this is I I and
you know not knowing the structure of
our organization to give you how alpha
this is I did the editorial work for
this and I'm not allowed to do editorial
work
they're like oh Chris oh
um uh uh
this won't work for everything
um uh but imagine oh
products
um imagine uh actually Gadgets in the
technological World which is great
because all the names are unambiguous
and it's easy to identify them
um uh uh uh celebrities movies
uh events
um uh and you have to understand that
it's often wrong
um uh and I I don't mean in the
aggregate I mean in the specific
so it'll Miss it'll miss a tribute uh um
a tweet as being
um actually everybody does this
um positive when it's negative but in
the aggregate it'll catch the sentiment
um uh in the aggregate it'll see that
the traffic is around uh uh concession
so we we actually uh um the concession
our concession tag uh we put in uh
before uh the uh the Iowa
um uh the Iowa caucus uh because we
figured we'd get somebody
um and and we got Bachmann uh and then
we got uh then we got Huntsman and one
by one we're gonna pick them off and
it's great and and I and I really and
what this thing is really do is it's
saying I'm gonna go through and I'm
gonna look at them all has anybody quit
hey oh Huntsman I'll say something about
Huntsman
um uh
so it's uh uh how do I put this so we're
treating we're treating Twitter as a
source for creating a data Repository
now an information repository but a data
repository uh where the tags have
specific meaning
um uh the uh the sentiment has specific
meaning
um uh we're just beginning to start
putting cloud in here to get some more
weight behind that all of these things
are noisy though uh and it's only in the
aggregate where you can begin to to trim
away a bit of that noise
um and for example I would never say
that John Huntsman dropped out of the
race
um uh because all I can say is that the
traffic indicates it
um and that ends up being an important
Point editorially yes
the uh what we're doing we're just doing
that we have a set of tracking terms
around the candidates to begin with
um all right
so
that's it that's all I got we transform
uh data into stories
questions
oh man I'm the guy who sent you the Bob
oh yeah the email a couple of days ago
so my Stanford PhD thesis uh 30 years
ago dealt with automated discovery of
enlarged clinical databases so I'd
recommend the area to you Chris yes
almost 20 of the economy
so here's a customer for you CDC in
Atlanta Georgia wants to know who's
getting sick what are people dying from
you know I'm I don't know quite how they
do their surveillance but uh I mean
they're
death reports they're it's just
mountains of data I mean it's a huge
area I know you're stretched it's
phenomenal uh I mean
I mean there was the whole big data push
was about the Mantra of meter and
monitor everything and there'll be gold
um and now we've hit a world where we
can meet her and monitor everything and
we know there's something there's
something in there and it's like
what is it
now the thing is is that the the
um and and we we do a little bit a
little bit of exploratory data analytics
but only a little bit and right now
we're in a world in which there is the
kind of analysis that we do really as a
reflection of the the the demands of the
story
um and really demands of what a customer
needs are on the media side what
business needs are on the business side
um uh uh the the end game here is
totally exploratory data analytics
um uh finding ways to name things but
then there's that the rest of what we do
uh and that is figuring out the angles
figuring out the uh figuring out the
language figuring out the structure
um but we're doing we're doing well I
mean we're doing some stuff in Farmer
it's great it's great I I've never
enjoyed myself as much as I am now I'm
gonna I'm gonna do him first yes
um you mentioned the customer couldn't
scale because they could only talk to 10
customers they could only talk to 10 of
their customers you have a customer that
they wanted they had 10 000 customers
and they could only talk to the top 10
some small number
is all the editorial work for using your
system done by your people or can your
customers do it
a question
um
um uh we um uh right now it's still I
mean we just we just we just we just are
are in the midst of exiting the world of
yaml and I got to tell you you go in and
you talk to Forbes and you tell them
here's a platform for you and by the way
you need someone on your editorial staff
to write yaml uh uh they won't even I
mean it's like they it's it's a it's a
horrible conversation to have and so
what we're doing right now is the tool
set that we have is for our internal use
but absolutely we want to have this out
in the world but it has to there's a
sort of a level of technical skill that
we're cutting away cutting away and
cutting away
so it all becomes editorial skill yes so
what's your replacement for yaml
oh underneath it's animal it's just it's
not exposed oh okay
I mean it's just not exposed I mean um
yeah I'm all in sheep's clothing it's
it's more and it's it's life protecting
them from the yaml it's more protecting
them from text Wrangler
um uh it's it's it's uh it's protected
from the syntax of it
um uh uh as opposed to uh the the
semantics that's reflected in the
structure of the FI of the of the of the
representation
yes
um
you said something there's a line in
there about you give us a data we'll
give you this the story and often
there's there could be 50 stories in the
same data set
um and sort of maybe connected to that I
was a journalist in the past life and I
sometimes I go on the story and then the
story would emerge from the
conversations it was like the emergent
properties of the data versus the kind
of
uh emerging properties yes
um uh this is actually attention in our
organization
um
uh uh there are those of us uh who
um there are those of us who want
structure
and say Here's the way the story is
going to be and there were those of us
who were saying why we have a looser
structure and just have it be the things
that are interesting will percolate up
um uh and so there's a little bit of
tension and we have a hybrid right now
between those two
um
but think about the the online marketing
performance reporting I'm taking this
data I'm talking to a client that's
gonna be one story I'm taking this data
I'm talking to the team it's a different
story
um uh the language is different the tone
is different the structure is different
what to do next is different
um uh the political stuff uh we right
now we sort of do an overview of the day
at the national level we have all the
state information everything's geotaged
so we can do it state by state we can do
a candidate by candidate we can do a
topic by topic and see the training of
the topic and all of that's supported by
the data and this depends upon um just
doing it
um
uh we
um uh in general we'll we strive to find
uh problems and data repositories that
will actually provide us with enough to
do not one story but a lot of stories
um and uh Finance has been great for
that because there's a there's some core
data that you use in a preview you use
it in the earnings report you can
actually do it to do stock alerts and we
actually watch the market and every
three minutes we look at 9 000 stocks
and we will tell you if something
interesting is happening to one of them
no
no ad finances Classics they say the
market drop
200 points today because as people say
well that's that's why we're reading
headlines uh because we want to be able
to say the market dropped today and they
don't say because they never say because
right right
or yeah it's like they sort of put on
the app what they believe to be the
cause I'm not saying it's a good thing
it's a bad thing I think but you know
but but being but being it but being
told stock went down you know American
Airlines stock went down today on news
and bankruptcy right wow uh
um uh uh uh Yahoo stock went down today
because of whatever they did
um I mean it's it's
um uh the uh but having the color around
it actually I think it uh improves the
story as long as you're careful about
not uh uh attributing that color to I
mean not not doing a causal attribution
um uh but yeah multiple story multiple
stories for single data repositories
absolutely
going to your do you okay at least as an
engineer I'd like to read your story and
then be able to click push down
through whatever process you had all the
way to the data oddly enough oddly
enough
nobody can sue you
um well
um
that's an interesting point
um right now when we work with when we
this is as a super interesting point
when we work with our clients
um we'll send them samples because we go
it's an iterative process we're writing
the story where the system's running the
story however you think oh and they mark
it up we literally send them like a PDF
or a word file and they'll mark it up
and they'll give it back to us and then
you have to look at it and go why the
hell did it say this
and you've got to track back into the
data
um and so we're actually working on a
tool for presenting information to
presenting samples to clients where they
can still mark it up but the act of
marking it up percolates through the
system so that we know every single
moment in the system in terms of every
decision it made every piece of data it
used everything that participated in
that decision so we can fix it
um and sometimes the fix is no actually
I you know the margin of Victory is
going to be bigger if you're gonna call
it a blowout
um uh but having that information is
super important for regular folk it's
not I mean it's not you know uh uh the
uh
I don't know what they want uh
no no no but but but
um you know for the kind of stuff we're
doing uh for doing now
um having it uh having it be a dynamic
document that bottoms out the data it's
not what it's not what people are
looking for and there might be a day
um uh but uh it's not what they're
looking for right now
that would have been interested in
getting access to that I mean that whole
but you are yeah but you are you may not
want us but you are an engineer
the finance guys might want to be able
to see the data easily too
um uh but not as a publishable story I
mean that's the thing is that that's
that's what we're building I'm gonna go
over here yeah picking up on that
earlier question which I thought brought
up something really interesting it seems
to be an assumption that you have a
priori structure or
fuzzy structure and the idea that I
thought was interesting here was the
notion of emergent structure and
Discovery potential in other words you
might have very strong structure at the
end of the day but you wouldn't have an
a priori yeah I mean
um uh I understand there are a couple
things that that uh the couple of
important points there
um one is that
um our a lot of what we create is
purposeful it has a point
um uh but a lot of what we also create
is
um is create to fit into a convention
and so for Forbes does preview stories
on their own and they also and we do
preview stories for them as well they
actually don't want us
to have a previous story that reads
entirely differently than their previous
stories and so they have a style guide
for us and most media organizations will
have a style guide we'll have an idea of
structure all of these things that um
they're not and they're not rigid by any
means
um uh but they give a shape to it and
even on the uh on the sports side
it's always the case in a baseball game
at the end of the story you talk about
the P you talk about the picture of the
winning team and you talk about how he
did and you just do it and everybody
wants it and if you don't do it people
will be angry at you
um uh now for other kinds of content
that's more reporting uh oriented that
actually ends up being there's an
emergent there's an emergent document
that comes out of it
um we're still at the stage where the
emergent document comes out of the
conversation with the client as to what
it is that they want and it's not purely
emergent from the data level because
we're still configuring the system and
we need to configure it so that it's
getting the right the right thing
um uh the further and further down the
line the more and more of that work will
be done by the system itself but
um
as you said behind you
um uh we got a lot on our plate
um there's so much data out there and
it's so unintelligible
um and and people are hungry it's it's
amazing they're hungry for the story
um uh and and if they have a story
already and we can tell them okay we can
give you ten thousand we can cover the
world with it
um uh that's exciting to them because
they can't they'll they'll have they'll
have the 10 stories that they can sell
to you know a million people each in
some sense they get that you know
everyone's interested I mean everyone's
interested in the Apple earnings report
but there are other earnings reports
that maybe 50 people are interested in
um and we can do those at scale and they
can get that they can make those people
happy they can get those people the
information they need in the form that
they're used to in the form that they
want
yes
Paul crewman famously writes about the
Dismal science and makes it interesting
and partly it's their point of view and
partly because he has all these uh
rhetorical techniques that he uses but
the remarkable thing is it's actually
interesting and it has a point of view
and has a focus and it's a pleasure to
read
can you match that we can't match that
but you're asking me that so you're
asking can I can do I have a system
that's 20 months old that can write as
well as a Nobel Prize winner writing for
the New York Times no
[Laughter]
no no uh
um
quite clearly there was there were two
things there were two there were two
statements that I've made relatively
recently actually one in the New York
Times and and one I was at uh O'Reilly's
uh O'Reilly does this thing called
newsfoo uh it's friends of our Riley and
they gathered journals together uh the
first thing is
um they came out of a talk that was
being given at medell we had a guy who
said oh you know ah I you know automated
systems are coming into play and he said
you know
20 years from now
um there's going to be a computer that
will write a story that will Pulitzer
and I raised my little hand and I said
this is going to be five years five
years
um and I'll be damned if it's not mine
um uh and I'm absolutely on record on
that and it's it's now
uh
it's it's six months ago yeah it's it's
uh but I know how we're gonna do it I
know how we're gonna do it um
that was the other well the the other
question the news food Camp somebody uh
oh he's sitting right there
somebody asked 15 years from now uh what
percentage of news is gonna be written
by machine
uh and I actually said I really don't
want to answer that question because I
was surrounded by journalists
I know it's pushed and pushed and pushed
and I said 90 90 of news will be written
by by machine
uh but understand what that 90 means
it's not that there's a pie right now
that is all the news that's being
written today and we'll get 90 of that
pie that pie will be enormous and the
pie will be personalized that will
probably be on point to your local area
the things you care about an intermix of
an intermix of politics and a con and
economic and economic data that is all
coming together for you so you can
understand it
um uh and the moment that we write a you
know once a day we write a a story for
every single person who you know in you
know the United States
um nobody asked about multilingual uh
every single person in the United States
um uh on that day we we got it we won I
mean in terms of that number
um and that number's that number's
coming
um uh because we can do something at
scale and this is actually an important
point I mentioned uh uh I mentioned
Little League
it's a company called Game Changer a
great company they have an iPhone app
that allows uh family members to score
Youth Sports in particular Little League
generating data like crazy so we have a
we have a relationship with them and
they once somebody says it's over we get
their data
um uh we write the story we send it back
our first version of this by the way was
we wrote the story in the form of a
college baseball uh story
um and uh and Game Changer said you guys
are are horribly cruel because we talk
about somebody failed and they're not
it's like No And so our our little
league stories are about success are
about effort uh are about about winning
even if you didn't win
um uh we wrote
350 000 of those last year Game Changer
was a game shakers are going along and
then they had his Booth another woof
um so uh it will probably be the case
that this year we'll write
um on the order of uh close to a million
stories
um uh for little league and maybe more
um my goal with regard to this is
um we write a game story for every
single little league game that's played
in this country we write it in English
we write it in Spanish and because I
live in Chicago we write it in Polish we
write it in a way in a in a form that
the kid can read his dad can read his
family can read his grandparent can read
no matter where they came from
um and cover local
any one story 20 people
takes you know
20 milliseconds to write
it's well worth the effort
oh I'm sorry I'm gonna say no because
you keep raising your hand and you just
asked before yeah it's all about scaling
you right now have 30 people
how many stories a day are going out um
we write on the order of one story every
30 seconds
and when you bring on something new like
this I mean how much human is involved
it takes a little bit of time I mean it
takes it takes I mean to go from no data
and we don't know what the story is to
data ingested everything in place uh all
of the editorial work done and we've got
a publishing pipeline takes about two
months but that's done something that
we're squeezing down squeezing down
squeezing down well that's prep yeah and
then once that pipelines in place and
the stories are incrementally set out
mode and we it's flipping a switch and
we never look we don't look at it we I
mean we look at them because
we care about the quality of our product
um uh but
um uh it's no longer editorial approval
on our side
then it becomes how does it get
distributed and who's who buys is it the
media company that buys it from you and
then distributes it through their
products yeah I mean that formed example
is Forbes
um yeah we we
um uh we and we and are the media
companies treat us like a writer
um we actually have one client
and Forbes would be one of the very few
clients who gives us a byline
um uh uh uh because some people are a
little nervous about the fact that it's
machine generated
um
sports but there's nothing no I know in
fact Game Changer though publishes on
their site and so we feed them so we
actually give our we give that we you
know we got data and then we we hand
content back to our clients
um
which the media infrastructure that's in
existence today is incapable of reaching
that's exactly right most people and
there's a challenge yeah but but all
this means is that what we think of as
journalists today are going to be you
know working for guys like you to set
this sort of system up they'll be met I
mean not all not in no way shape or form
will it be all a journalists
um but I think that what will happen is
you'll have I mean you'll have you have
a you have a newsroom and they'll be
they'll be your your your your
traditional mold journalists they'll be
the guys who are who are curating uh
social content
um uh and then there'll be the guys who
are actually working with uh as a meta
journalist working with configuring and
doing uh and doing data ingestion and
and generation that way I think we're
just going to be another arrow in the
quiver
um uh and I mean it's already social
social and uh and user generated content
that's already coming in
and
go programmer was a complicated thing
and then somebody that had spreadsheets
and then somebody invented web the web
and then somebody got a wrapper so that
ordinary people can make web pages oh no
and well and we'll have to be that that
journalists
can become meta journalists and they can
say this is how I want the story to be
and it'll have their tone and their
language and their voice and their
analysis and that's like to be able to
say yesterday I wrote one story
today I wrote the same story for 5 000
Metro areas it's like wow that's
incredible to have that kind of reach
the economist famously gives credit to
none of their journalists no journalists
no writer gets a byline is this a
business opportunity for you
um uh
probably not
um probably not uh they are uh they're
one of the uh the um
uh I mean they have a clear focus and
Mission and
um that's very different than they're
very different than ours very different
than ours all right I'm gonna email your
hands on up do you still have a question
all right
um uh um I'll take one more and then I
gotta go and I gotta stop because I'm
now actually beyond my time okay okay
when the camera goes off you can tell us
the real truth all right
you're so dominated industry that most
of the
Missile Road
um
um we have a we have a system
um that is a parallel system that is
also in Alpha that reads headlines
um in the financial realm and we read
our own headlines
um
uh and feedback
uh but that's uh but yeah actually oddly
enough uh because of uh some things our
headlines
um are because of very we try to add as
much variability as possible our
headlines are ever so slightly harder to
read than a lot of others
um um they're not metaphorical which are
impossible to deal with but they're um
they've got some interesting structural
elements
okay
that's it then
thank you